rise of the robots and this is a story
that's never ending heavily treated in
science-fiction platforms for all in all
frontiers servant robots military robots
sex robots and maybe that's inevitable
given the the direction technology and
computing and artificial intelligence is
going with regard to how much we might
use a robot in war such that you don't
feel the pain you don't bleed anymore
because of machine is fighting for you
there that's been treated also there's
an episode of Star Trek we're in its
50th anniversary this year an episode of
Star Trek where countries were fighting
each other by computer and it would
decide ok we won this battle and we
killed a hundred of us enough sent a
hundred of you to this extermination
chamber and that would be the
consequence of the war fought by the
computers that's and that's just kind of
weird where is the blood where is the
pain where is the suffering so that you
know not to do that again the next time
and maybe the real solution here is not
whether we ever have robots in the
service of war maybe we will mature
sufficiently as a species so that any
conversation about war would be purely
historical then we don't have to talk
about military robots
maybe that's the future